welcome to this video playing hmm XG x
DX fifth okay from greece and let's see
what we get yeah the dutch defense tried
something else here not allowing a usual
stone wall okay maybe I can try
something like that with d5 coming
cancelled t5 okay let's at least an
interesting position ed 594 is the idea
anyway 94 of course getting pressure in
the center on the six ball that's the
idea
isn't this isn't this a nice square 96
let this is funny move I mean 94 was
very obvious that this is my next move
ready okay now I can decide I can take
the exchange I can take the pawn it's a
it's both okay but maybe still the
exchange I guess so hmm ok let's just
take this and now maybe a for getting
the bishop to d4 if you move to the pawn
I need to to open up the position in the
long run for the rooks yeah i can i can
give up on this is not not really a big
problem I need to open up the position
that's more important cake or g 4g 4s in
general took a good idea here in this
position type
but I couldn't play it right away it
needs just a bit of preparation yeah I
need to make sure that my bishop is
doing something here if I don't react he
might shut it off completely with age
five and moves like that yeah I think I
should probably probably should have
probably should have taken know the porn
instead of the exchange this is probably
okay for me here but it's not so
convincing try to play quickly not to
get into a big time time travel but down
and maybe I should have taken a five
emphasis easy m and this close type of
position the exchange wasn't so I'm so
valuable
so probably take it and Queen d2 or
Queen d2 immediately yeah going to
immediately is also good rook takes rook
takes rook g5 this is what I want to do
yeah are here proc g5 immediately is
also good takes pawn takes Queen
somewhere Bishop f5 is not working but
closed Brook f1 okay from one there's
III that's not good
who
yeah it's not not not totally easy this
III move as so really irritating and
once he has taken with the bishop you
can play Bishop to e6
this isn't so clear well
this really isn't so clear this position
and probably I'm just a stupid to play
it but but I really I really didn't see
a complete win get this Bishop is
protecting everyone I cannot play rook
everyone in this position and he
threatened III really look everyone that
was III I'm ideas Queen f2h for h6 maybe
maybe this is still saving the day
I cannot take 12 game and no here how
are you defending the snow queen age six
should be dangerous really yeah no
Bishop takes and look everyone something
like that
what can I take you had Queen h3 check
actually creates recheck King g6 this
check check Queenie for check time
warning Jack not calculated to the end
but the try it really looks like a win
check now let's check this briefly is
there anything better channeling always
flick this in check didn't I don't see
em later in check and now is there some
move the Cystic here it's irritating me
so probably I should just just take him
so it does not really have a great move
I believe
well there is nothing look not have to
check King g2 after that he has no move
I didn't see a mate but it looks like
there should be one but I didn't sound
resigns that's a let's check this as
their checkmate no computer who would
put show a mate but there is none the
plus 8 is chapter with the gang
continuation check check yeah and and
it's it's it's really lost but this was
interesting I really played this totally
totally wrong I mean here here I should
probably take I should probably take on
f5 it's maybe the easier way just get a
pawn this night can go back if needed to
defend see for this is maybe the better
way to play oops this was not what I
wanted to do and here i need to do any
to play differently really once he gets
see for it it gets tricky maybe bishop
age 30 or maybe this one maybe just give
up one pawn for the sake of structure
this would be this year this would help
but I think the pawn drab has better
taking 105 to the pawn is better than
taking the exchange the way it went it
wasn't totally clear really he got he
got this porn and no maybe yeah maybe I
should just protected him queen bee
three yeah this better protected for the
moment what I didn't really appreciate
is that d5 is immediately week as well
and here I don't know here maybe he can
play something more dynamic black
already has a pawn and this is not a
great piece yeah this wasn't this wasn't
really good and now
I was very quickly getting there and
this is what's this was very important
that I got this in here here I have a
good news this is nice yeah and here I
acumen c3 always gives a check out
droopy g3 okay and this year this was
surprisingly surprisingly tough my
original idea of course was this but he
plays a 3 and III and I don't really
have a great move he just changes take
this and maybe here and what yeah it's
not not totally convincing two-tier
Queen f2h freue this is again good for
white yeah it's a very tough position
with one or two minutes you will make
mistakes regardless of your you're
playing strength yeah it was interesting
though thanks for watching